hey sorry I'm late buddy no no you said  12 I said 12 ish plus that map you gave  me wasn't complete like at all oh come  on don't be that way I have a good  excuse I was with the folks from star  wars force for change they have this new  campaign sponsored by Crowdrise show  your force so you can donate to four  great charities and have a chance to win  awesome Star Wars prices this week the  first four people to donate or raise at  least five hundred dollars will have the  chance to win a Star Wars prize pack  including a sign bb-8 no no not not you  not you this check it out yeah it's  pretty cool huh and what's more the top  fundraiser this week has the chance to  win an exclusive tour of Lucasfilm in  San Francisco or they'll get a screening  of their favorite Star Wars movie so  what do you say are you in yes I know  you wouldn't let me down pal show your  force and visit Crowdrise calm / force  for change for full details and become a  force for change  you